good morning everybody welcome to
megabit it's a start of a new week one
player I think it's not like one and a
half players maybe yeah uh we're gonna
play Castlevania Symphony of the Night
today because why not it's a great game
look at the item don't see what they are
you want to see you want to see what we
won't get Oh future you're saying
there's okay okay I see what you're
saying I thought you're saying if you
got them as Richter than Alec Harper
have them no saying is that if you pick
them up now is Rick alucard you just
denying them from alucard because what a
firebrand too bad bad oh what's that you
want the moon rod anyway dark sword
shield bottom there where's the moon
right there's a moon rod oh my moon rod
what is a man I'm miserable little pile
of secrets funny enough talk how about
you oh so good so good almost maybe the
best oh you're going super saiyan on
this dude
oh you're not gonna you're not gonna
you're Dino street hotel after a little
filly Lewis leg you such skill hey that
kid don't get again though you're gonna
kill yourself yeah we gotta show them
winter a little bit and magic spirit
most come out if you also get absolutely
no smoke have you played no other
Castlevania games dread coming to this
fight and all these things are happening
I'm like am I supposed to know these
characters that I just finished the game
and who took this photo I want yeah did
I load some sort of say file on my
memory car by accident oh here we go
such a badass intro this is this a game
look at all that scrolling but I can and
you cease your attack but I my own you
will not you stowed it does work again
all my stuff or maybe I get a short
sorta then I get the rest brain Africa
and now here you are short a skeleton i
freakin hate skeletons don't even get me
started against family skeletons bro and
the moonwalk I'll the moonwalk moonwalk
so good cuz our cursor class I guess
much class such a plan ego Cody you go
to actually instead of talking to you
see and so this game kind of pioneered
the the Metroidvania category of games
we're all sort of like used to now we're
just sort of like a super metroid ask
game with like a big map and lots of
secrets hidden in the walls and stuff he
actually said that he meant to make a
game that was similarly of all things so
even though we've got this map here
that's reminiscent of like super metroid
right that's just sort of like the
consequence of a 2-d game like our side
scrolling 2-d game it's not actually
trying to mimic super metroid these guys
with the bag of dicks yeah pic oh ho
heck it but the game does very nicely
give you
acts sub weapon right into this fight
which is really the ideal weapon you
take out this so-called wagon food
Tiffany's bags OD yeah these guys don't
really believe all right take your time
turkey time that's how to roast it out
dudes in the background is comedy yeah I
seems in the production studio real
height for the pot roast right now this
guy is the best not only does Phoebe
bleed everywhere but he also explore
foods wait and then he explode this is
the other clock room these are the fries
are my most hated enemies the freemen
plea because like even if I can just get
past them like I can I want to kill them
because they're so obnoxious you seen
human and yet what do you hear what do
you call me destroy this castle yeah
maybe the bat is the first item you have
it lets you do always oh not the table
and he made you pick up I uh oh the
worst is this table is destroying you
okay oh so I can't jump up there so what
you got to know then is that there's
some secret gotta be some guy through a
wall there's so many pot roasts in that
wall right now that you cannot enjoy yet
yeah go back look at that big eyeball
back there I hadn't noticed that before
you see him out there out the window
yeah I see you out there I see what you
doing in their own car see you I need to
use something yeah no I mean why please
say please say yeah just for the stream
you care mom smart bomb this dude
oh no oh you shut down all but you gotta
luck what's the books i like how in this
game full of skeletons and diamond plant
monsters it's like the table the book
the paintings or through the most
hazardous things or things i always get
hit by i cannot add one who opposes the
master you won't go unrewarded oh that
crazy need I don't know what you got out
of it sadly we have still not found that
state point Peter still teetering on the
brink last recording with disaster I
know shamim on your house Oh get rocked
you've got to be carrying all right wait
no got a lot on surely the water will
halfway just be cool just oh damn it
just be cool max I need to pause the
game I need to look at the map curse
clouds Oh numbers oh no hits don't know
you know where those hearts gave me
he'll know if you just pick up the
Lord's sure there i want to say there is
i want to say I'm homeless okay no don't
fight just go back I have no choice we
can't go back there's more Yorick's max
I hate this I know this is the worst I'm
gonna disappoint everybody i know i'm
gonna do this in style oh yeah talk
about tension yeah you've done it yeah a
half circle back to forward back to
forward door armed officers who man I'm
still feeling icky got the shakes I got
this Jimmy shake
oh oh nothing the doses oh the worst at
sea now i wish i had a blast of the game
now i wish i had the Bible oh god poor
bird I don't remember that bird mystery
bird what are you guys doing set up a
whole like narrative down here or
they're gonna they're gonna like
attacking oh good oh there it is stick
and move again got those X peas oh lucky
how's bad this bad again it's been from
okay to just bad all over again very
quickly Marrakech although you don't
have a microphone looking I kept like
lean in like this don't get done today
all right now oh yeah Mary thanks for
stopping by Mary just okay
I'll get you by the shield out bro yeah
yeah yeah we're burning in water how
could this be a classic part of you
counsel me here opening oh oh you are
hard yeah let's go this way yeah like
their concepts for every guy your
counter what if they have like a really
like irritating squeaky boys yeah yeah
like that Bell like that one cuz our car
is like really moody whatever should we
need a way to sort of balance that out
uh-huh but yeah symphony tonight yeah
we're playing it on xbox 360 but you can
find out in all sorts of different form
there's a bird yeah every year has a
version for PSP for Vita for playstation
3 4 playstation 4 sega saturn if you've
got a japanese saturn and on xbox truly
one of gaming's great Peter thank you
coming in showing it off on your own
stream I don't know why I'm thanking you
happy Monday or happy Monday everyone
yeah so remember megabit we got a new
scheduling up megabit is on 11 a.m. on
mondays at 2pm we've got multiple
players with Chris waters oh thanks for
watching everybody Maxwell McGee thank
you for watching my for me here Peter
Brown now see you guys next Monday where
we're gonna be playing starfox with this
grab a boob Weber the way they're gonna
take